phil what are the biggest obstacles that
have held you back from being a
hollywood director
well i'm yeah i'm still chasing that
can't quite call myself a highway
director yet
um so what is holding me back um
maybe location i think um
you know people say you know and
there's obviously there's a kind of
pre-covered and maybe
you know postcoded answer to this about
working
any from anywhere but um uh
you know i feel that um it's
it's hard to try and make
big commercial film in a country
that doesn't have a studio system
that doesn't seem to want to support
that kind of filmmaking
um and it's
and that that's that's hard you know
when you think
well how am i going to make that film
you know
when there isn't funding or there's
nowhere to go to or there's no one to
pitch to or there's no one to network
with particularly that's going to help
you make that film because actually
a lot of the big film a lot of the film
i want to make is funded by studios it's
funded
you know stateside um so
that feels like uh
i'd say a frustration with being a
british filmmaker
and and you can really see why we lose
say lose talent but we see a lot of
people go across the pond
you know because unless you're wanting
to make us
a particular type of film um which we do
very well we're very good at um which is
maybe more outhouse leaning that's maybe
more
uh you know lower budget kind of lower
scale that kind of thing
which you know the films i very much
enjoy watching but the films i don't
really want to make
you know and i feel like it's
frustrating
um that on the one hand
it's very lucky that we have this kind
of public
money lottery funding side of our
industry
but also completely frustrating when you
think well
why aren't we trying to have a studio
why are we trying to make more
commercial fare why are we trying to
make our john wicks or our trilogies or
you know it's like we have as in the uk
we we made the harry potters we make the
star wars we make the james bonds like
like we have an amazing you know from
visual effects to crew to studios
there's a reason why people come and
film here
and great directors that are you know
from here
um as well so it feels rather strange to
have to
you know go to the studios which feels
like a million miles away especially
with someone you know
growing up and trying to do it and you
know not being able to jump on a plane
you know and not feeling like you have
those connections yet
you know before i had a manager and
stuff over there you
you kind of uh it feels like another and
like another world
um and then then also there's no way you
can go
you know to pitch your film you know
where actually someone
could go and make it you know and i feel
that
um you know
maybe it's controversial to say maybe
it's not but i just feel like
you know i feel like that public money
that
the kind of bfi side of you know
filmmaking is that
we should be looking at making
trying to tell more stories that appeal
to more people
and i know on paper it's very hard to
know what makes money what doesn't make
money so
it's very hard to go down you know to be
too generalized about it
but you know there are certain genres
and certain stories that
are going to appeal to a much wider
audience versus
another film that's only going to appeal
to you know
a a a much smaller audience you know um
in terms of like not the multiplexers
not the mainstream kind of things and
yes of course things break out
and and they do but to not actually
explore those
ideas or hear those pictures or just
wanting
want to make that out and out action
film or the out and out
you know i don't know why john wick's in
my head but it's like why couldn't we
make john wick in the uk
why couldn't we have funded that and
make that like there's no reason why we
couldn't have made it we're just not
seemingly wanting to make that stuff and
that's that's frustrating
because i want to make films here i want
to you know and
and i feel that sometimes the wall is
pulled over our eyes of like
well you are making stars you are making
james bond you are making harry potter
like what are these amazing films like
yeah but we don't have any ownership
of them we don't actually own them like
we service them
and then we then we hand them back you
know
so um it would have been wonderful
you know for maybe some of our uk tax
credit money
that's that you know is helping bring
those films here and get our crews and
our people working which is
vitally important to our economy but
also maybe having a little slice of the
pie for that you know um
what you know what is what is one
percent of our harry potter
franchise worth you know i know until
you have real one percent not hollywood
accounting one percent
you know what is that worth well to us
that's that's
that's the money to support filmmakers
that's that's money
to support people to make more short
films to make more
indie films to take more risks and i
think
what is frustrating as well is that
um maybe more is industry as a whole but
especially in this country it's like
you know you feel like you can't fail
you know it's like
that first feature needs to win sundance
or you're done
you know i mean it's like hang on
where did that pressure come from like
we're all like trying to grow and
nurture our filmmaking here
so so you know it's a very very
rare rare rare thing that you make one
thing it's your very first thing
and you you just win like that's it
you've you've made it you know that
the chances of that are you know i don't
know what the statistical chance is that
but they're near impossible
so if that's impossible what makes that
more possible well it's actually having
funding and support
to help filmmakers make more film
to grow and so when they get that
feature film when they
you know make can make those films then
they have permission to fail
and you know it's something actually
paul greengrass
uh talks a lot about um because
you know he he cut his teeth in
documentaries and
and making films funny enough in my
hometown in
in you know the grenada region um
and and he quite right he said like a
lot of them didn't work
you know and and and some of them
weren't as good as they should have been
or like i learned a lot doing them
and this is paul greengrass what happens
if paul greengrass
made one film and no one gave him
another opportunity
what we would have been missing out on
you know so
i think there's a pro i think there's a
real problem
for me um uh
and um this has turned into a british
film ministry rant
but if this that feels like my
obstacle to
in inverted coma say a hollywood
director in terms of making big
mainstream fair
obviously the literal version making
making a hollywood being a horror
director is making a film in hollywood
and what's stopping that is well you
know a few things
stopping that but um but not for one of
trying and and
there are things bubbling away that
might make that happen
but again that's only 15 plus years into
doing this as a job so it's that
building those contacts and
relationships and that
trust you know and and so when you have
that opportunity
um you know you can grab it with both
hands
so yeah it's um
yeah i just i just think i just wish
that we made
um more you know more commercial film
in this country uh and we just yeah and
we and we had ownership of
the upside to then invest in more film
you know i feel like we have a film
charity here and not a film business and
i feel that's that's the wrong
mindset um and
uh and that and that can be quite
frustrating wanting to make commercial
film
and do you think just just wrapping up
on this topic but do you think just
having grown up in the uk that it's kind
of the grass is always greener
myself for a teenager i love the uk i
had a union jack t-shirt that i bought
from a store
so and i was just treasuring it that it
was that was from you know europe and
and
i think the grass is always greener and
i wasn't as much into the tentpole
movies
so i'd rather watch christopher nolan's
following than inception but that's just
because
i grew up being surrounded by that and i
just wonder if it's just maybe just a
personal taste as well
just because it seems so unique and
special
yeah it is it is a personal taste and
the grass is
the grass is greener um but you know
i it goes back to the films that i
watched
as a kid that made me want to be a
filmmaker and they were big american
films
you know and uh so now i i want to make
those films
plus certain things in american accent
are way cooler when you write them in a
script
than someone in the british accent like
you know the person can get away with
that is you know
is uh is is like villains in like a bond
film
um but um uh but it's
it's it's it it just comes down to that
sensibility
of of i i i i go to movies
for escapism um
and also to be moved and if people
filmmakers
very confirmed i can slide in um
you know interesting thought or analysis
or comment
on society a problem the world then
wonderful you know that that's the icing
that's that that is
you know as a filmmaker the bond
probably pours it together but as an
audience member it's like the icing on
the cake to make you think about that
kind of stuff
um but it's um it's
uh it's just comes back to that you know
i aspire
to make you know america commercial film
in wide or you know wide releases to try
and appeal to
as many people as possible um
as opposed to quieter film um that
you know maybe more insular
you know yeah but that's just my
preference
you